plusieurs personnes expriment leur
inquiétude pour la suite des choses si
notamment le président antoine devait
résister à reconnaître les résultats si
tenté qu'il était défait dans cette
élection mode invité francis langlois
membre associé de l'observatoire sur les
états unis de la chaire raoul dandurand
professeur d'histoire au cégep de
trois-rivières bonsoir francis langlois
est là vous êtes vous inquiet non je
pense pas qu'il va y avoir de violence à
grande échelle
évidemment il peut y avoir des
accrochages ponctuel peut y avoir des
débordements dans certaines sorties de
certains événements comme trop festif ou
peut-être un petit peu trop aigri par le
résultat mais je pense pas qu'il va y
avoir d'affrontement comme certains
delon affirmé dans les dernières
semaines n'ont pas ce qui est arrivé je
croise pas si monsieur pas s'être les
défis aujourd'hui ou hier il y avait des
gens qui se présentaient armés aux
abords des bureaux de dépouillement des
premiers offices électoraux et à la main
je pense est celui du nevada ce matin
qui disait avoir de la sécurité parce
qu'ils craignaient pour la sécurité des
membres est ce que les appels je pense à
monsieur tremblay lorsqu'il parlait lors
du dernier débat là
ou à certains groupes standby stand up
la promo ses propos de ce soir pour être
perdant 10 ans ne serait pas faire ça
peuvent être perçus comme un appel à une
résistance en fait c'est exactement la
différence entre aujourd'hui et les
grandes émeutes manifestations et grande
flambée de violences des années 60 c'est
que des gens que plus extrémistes
trouvent écho à la maison blanche et
effectivement il ya une certaine frange
beaucoup plus à droite un qui veut
reprendre les choses en main qui a été
encouragé par le président et qui risque
effectivement de prendre les choses en
main si on le veut de cette donc prendre
les armes et donc de descendre dans la
rue et de mettre la pression par la
violence sur les officiels déjà qu'on
constituent souvent à droite qu'on
appelle des accélérations ni ce temps
des gens qui veulent faire arriver plus
vite la grande utopie blanche ou encore
déjà des supporteurs du présidents qui
ont déjà manifesté de façon armés on l'a
vu par exemple dancing au michigan qui
sont allés voir au capitole les élus
hésitent à la avec gilet pare-balles
fusils d'assaut et où ils disaient
qu'ils étaient là de façon pacifique
mais évidemment sauf a visité par des
gens qui sont armés
c'est une forme d'intimidation la même
chose ces gens l'ont aussi eux disaient
qu'ils étaient pour encadrer les
manifestations qui entourait bon la mort
de trouille du fleuve dont les
manifestations tenues par notamment de
l'acteur majeur
ces gens là étaient là aussi pour
intimider la population qui bien
évidemment on a vu des accrochages à
kenosha par exemple ou la mort
ça risque d'arriver parce que monsieur
trump lors de la campagne souvent accusé
monsieur byden d'être resté silencieux
devant s'il appelait des
émeutes généralisées à l'ensemble des
manifestations en disant qu'il y avait
dans ton de la violence du cassage une
sorte de débordements et monsieur
buydens et non 99% des manifestations
sont pacifiques alors que et on a vu des
milices à l'oeuvre dans les derniers
mois
est-ce que la violence en qu'un oui
effectivement elle est généralement
situé à droite donc si on regarde la
violence armée
les attentats qui sont commis aux états
unis la vaste majorité sont engendrées
par l'extrême droite
effectivement à gauche en un petit peu
oui oui il ya eu du terrorisme islamiste
aux états unis mais les morts les
attentats des attaques et évidemment la
propagande rouler les propos haineux
sont tenues essentiellement à droite un
rapport du béa et publiée en octobre
2020 le mentionne c'est de marquer la
page 18
donc que la vraie menace ne menace la
plus potentiellement aux états unis de
dons de problèmes de sécurité si on veut
ses tenues par les suprémacistes là et
la frange est ré accélération liste du
mouvement d'extrême droite
c'est clair est ce que l'esprit de la
constitution du deuxième amendement avec
la reconnaissance de ces milices n'est
pas l'esprit ce que certains pour
interpréter la chose disons que monsieur
scénario monsieur byden gagne
monsieur tron résiste conteste les
tribunaux vont pas assez vite à son goût
enfin est-ce que les milices peuvent
venir à la rescousse de toi c'est celui
qui peut faire du grabuge et s'étendit
vous parlez du deuxième amendement dans
lequel on dit bien que dans le cas d'une
minute bien ordonné mais le grenat ne
peut pas empêcher les gens de posséder
des armes à feu le je t'aime et ses
courses a dit on dit bien bilis bien
ordonnée donc une milice organisée par
le gouvernement à un groupe de personnes
armées qui présentent leurs mains
l'application de la loi et l'ordre qui
présentent leurs mains la loi le
gouvernement qui décide de se faire
justice et par ailleurs la plupart des
états aux états unis ont des lois qui
interdisent
la formation de telles milices armées
qui interviendrait disons pour remplacer
la police ou entre bref l'appareil de
sécurité de l'état donc c'est un
détournement de sens du deuxième
amendement qui a été fait et ça s'est
fait sur 30 ans à des taux moins des
années 90 ans le quittait un peu l'âge
d'or des milices qui sont réapparus
essentiellement de plus depuis 2008 dont
clesles l'élection de barack obama pour
eux pour les gens l'extrême droite
c'était vraiment le l'avènement d'une
nouvelle ère doit être la première étape
de l'avènement d'un nouvel ordre à ce
que le plan de masse comme le contrôle
de la population est repris mais
l'ensemble des populations
alors quand une situation à suivre on ne
souhaite pas de d'explosion de violence
bien sur mon compte sur vous pour nous
éclairer sur ces situations là francis
langlois toujours un plaisir de vous
parler merci d'avoir accepté dans son
éducation